jetzt ist mein kollege sebastian geisler
aus der politikredaktion weil mir hallo
wir wollen jetzt erst mal erklären was
in welchem bundesland eigentlich geld
das ist ein riesen würmer kein blick
mehr durch jeden tag gibt es neue regeln
sebastian schauen wir erstmal auf die
masken pflicht die herrscht der
deutschlandweit aber wo ist jetzt masken
pflicht im öffentlichen raum also wo ist
die erweiterte masken pflicht genau wir
müssen ja sagen masken pflicht es geht
natürlich weiterhin wir haben uns ja
schon daran gewöhnt im öffentlichen
personennahverkehr also in bus und bahn
in allem und so weiter maske zu tragen
die erweiterte massen pflicht das
schauen wir euch mal auf die grafik also
in bayern in baden württemberg in
nordrhein westfalen in hamburg geht
jetzt die sogenannte erweiterte massen
pflicht so das heißt es soll an
öffentlichen plätzen überall da wo man
nicht so gut abstand halten kann also
beispielsweise auf vier plätzen von
bahnhöfen oder in bürogebäuden und so
weiter in theatern gilt maske auf das
ist die faustregel dass kann man sagen
das ist auch in fußgängerzonen der fall
beispielsweise alle verkehrsflächen wo
man mit menschen in kontakt ist in
kantinen beispielsweise von betrieben
und so etwas faustregel nochmal ganz
klar viele menschen im raum bedeutet
maske auf und du hast auch noch gesagt
etwas zu schulen da gibt es auch
besondere masken pflicht regeln
ja absolut also die lagen in den schulen
ist da etwas speziell das muss man sich
noch mal genauer ansehen bei einem
inzidenz wert von 50 infizierten auf
100000 einwohner gilt in schulen in
bayern auch im unterricht die massen
pflicht das ist in münchen bereits jetzt
der fall muss man sagen
in nordrhein westfalen und in berlin
können schulleiter das für ihre schulen
anordnen sie müssen ist aber noch nicht
tun
in hessen müssen alle schüler schüler
sogar unabhängig vom sogenannten
incidents wert die maske tragen in
niedersachsen im unterricht auch keine
massen pflicht in sachsen-anhalt gar
keiner massen pflicht für schüler auch
nicht auf dem schulgelände dann kommen
wir jetzt zum beherbergungs verbot dass
es auch noch mal wahnsinnig spannend
weil auch der riesenwirbel wo geht es
denn jetzt und wo nicht
also freitag haben bayern und hessen
erklärt dass sie dieses umstrittene
unterbringungs verbot für touristen aus
risikogebieten wieder abschaffen
damit kamen sie möglicherweise richter
sprüchen zuvor denn zuvor haben in baden
württemberg und niedersachsen gerichte
diese verbote gekippt
die begründung war das sei ein
verfassungswidriger unverhältnismäßiger
eingriff in die grundrechte
so gestern folgte dann am späten abend
in brandenburg das oberwaltungsgericht
hat da zwei anträgen stattgegeben und
das hotel verbot gestoppt ich kann also
auch in brandenburg ohne einschränkungen
wieder in hotels einchecken so in
schleswig-holstein entschied am freitag
das gericht dass das dortige
beherbergungs verbot aber rechtmäßig sei
da hat in der familie aus nordrhein
westfalen geklagt die wollten gern auf
sylt urlaub machen eigentlich das
oberverwaltungsgericht hat den antrag
aber abgelehnt die haben gesagt der
schutz der bevölkerung vor gunnar dieth
vor
man darf muss man dazu sagen durchaus
noch nach schleswig holstein fahren
man muss aber in hotels und auch
ferienhäusern mein vermieter oder dem
personal beim einchecken einen negativen
corona test vorweisen und der darf nicht
älter als 48 stunden seien und denen
muss man natürlich erstmal bekommen sind
ist das ist auch alles wirklich sehr
undurchsichtig muss man sich informieren
kommen wir zu punkt 3 zur sperrstunde
nehmen wo geht die denn jetzt in welchem
bundesland wir haben ja gerade den film
gesehen aus berlin da es jetzt gekippt
worden wieder für elf gastronom
genauso sieht es also am freitag hat das
berliner verwaltungsgericht diese 23 uhr
sperrstunde in der hauptstadt gekippt
die aufhebung gilt jetzt erst mal aber
nur für die wirte die da tatsächlich gab
es eben gesehenen beitrag geklagt haben
alkohol dürfen die nach 23 uhr aber
weiter nicht aus schenken dh ich kann in
diesen in diesen kneipen dort sitzen
bleiben kriegt aber ab 23 uhr kein
frisch gezapftes bier beispielsweise so
der senat hatte ja beschlossen dass
restaurants bars kneipen und später
zwischen 23 und 6 uhr geschlossen
bleiben müssen
diese regelung wird dann wohl ganz
wegfallen erstmal nur diesen elf bars
und kneipen
kurios ist allerdings wenn wir uns das
auf der karte vielleicht ruhig noch mal
anschauen ungeachtet dieses urteils in
bayern hat parallel jetzt die
landesregierung in nordrhein-westfalen
im grunde die gleiche sperrstunden
regelung beschlossen
nur eben für nrw das heißt hier ist ab
23 uhr zu es ist genau das was in berlin
jetzt wegfallen soll
interessant ist übrigens kann man durch
noch das sehen wir auch punktuell
vielleicht auf der karte
essen ist in frankfurt am main eine
regelung in kraft ganz ähnlich wie die
anderen beiden genannten regeln jetzt da
ist auch zwischen 23 und 6 uhr zur bars
kneipen restaurants sind dann
geschlossen und es geht in der zeit
natürlich auch generelles alkoholverbot
also sebastian weiterhin riesenwirrwarr
danke trotzdem für eine einordnung wir
haben es zumindest jetzt mal versuchte
alles zusammen zu bündeln vielen dank
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren